svetlana is with us in san francisco hi
svetlana how are you
hi dave oh my god i'm so excited sorry
i'm gonna contain myself
me too me too what's up so
um i we live in the san francisco bay
area we're in the suburbs of the city
we um we sold our first home that we had
for five years last year in
august because we thought oh my god it's
the height of the market let's do this
let's sell
well um lo and behold it wasn't the
height of the market
and now we're renting we thought we'd
run into winter to
wait for the prices to drop they keep
going up interest rates are low
should we just dive in and buy now um
prices are insane in our area or do we
just continue to wait which i'm just
worried that we're just throwing away
money renting if we do that
yeah well the san francisco market
and silicon valley in particular some of
the most expensive real estate in the
world as you know yeah and um and it is
it has done nothing but go up if you are
going to stay
in the area owning real estate owning
real estate
is the best thing to do i do not
know if it's going to go down or not
but if you're going to stay in the area
say let's pick a number 10 years
okay the market may get soft in
california
between now and the 10-year mark it
could even go
down in value but 10 years from today i
would be
very comfortable and glad that i owned
that i owned real estate i think i think
okay and what i'm basing that on is this
california's always been a an expensive
real estate market san francisco the
bullseye
um and uh uh and it has always had
more fluctuation it's always gone up and
down and you add to that the political
climate you've got and the economic
climate as a result of new
shutting everything down the huge number
of millions of people leaving california
and what what is that supply demand
going to do to drive real estate prices
down it might
it might i don't know it hasn't yet
that's what we're i'm not sure i've not
seen
none of our none of our real estate elps
are telling us the market is soft
in california that there's an oversupply
of real estate
due to the number of people leaving the
state yet
but i that that's a possibility i do
think that will be a short-lived
possibility because i do believe that
californians are going to
get their lives back by removing
governors or electing new governors or
whatever
over some period of time i don't expect
the current status to last
10 years that would be a weird thing
um but but it has gone you know it has
gotten
considerably harder to live there over
the last 20 years
economically yep so all of that effect
all of that affects real estate prices
that's what you've got to consider
so um i i don't i still wouldn't believe
in the real estate market on the long
haul though
on a three year or a five year window i
don't know i've never seen anything like
this the number of people leaving a
given state
and they're all the wealthy people and
the producers that's who's leaving
because they don't want to get taxed
with the wealth tax they don't want to
get taxed the way they've been over
taxed they don't want
you know they don't want to pay for all
these things when the climate has become
anti-business
and so on so it's affecting the economy
the political
uh left is affecting the economy the
political shutdowns on covet
is affecting the economy versus i was in
florida last week
and it's a freaking boom town you can't
get in a restaurant you can't get in a
hotel
um and you know again the political
climate is that governor has opened that
state up
and uh boom man people are out there
and so um here in florida owning real
estate you know you're gonna be a real
happy camper
in the three-year mark the two-year mark
the five-year mark the 10-year mark
but that's the thing you're facing and
that's what you've got to think through
and watch for yourself
but overall if you think we're going to
be here 10 years no matter what happens
here we're sticking it out
then boom i would buy that's simple
hey thanks for the call